so you ever wake up from a nightmare
you're like huh sharks then you realize
you're safe at home you're like ah my
life so I had ice cream the other night
yeah exactly it's a different experience
as an adult it is as a kid right you
have ice cream as a kid you know all
your friends are around it's daytime
it's joyful yeah the advice came as an
adult it's dark you're by yourself
you're a load
talking to yourself I should be doing
this this is stupid this is stupid
do you ever have somebody walk in on you
when you're eating ice cream
anybody dog kitty bored see the sock on
the door so but you got to do what makes
you happy you know you got to get happy
happy is important you know a lot of
people a lot of people smoke pot to be
happy yeah you know that works cause
people who smoke pot are always gritted
right they always got that grin like
they got a secret you know what their
secret is they're high everybody knows
it
a lot of people so many people smoke pot
nose crazy
used to be a smaller percentage of
people like when I was in high school
it's just a small percentage of people
that smoke pot and everybody knew who
they were that guy smokes pot how do you
know he's by the dumpster he's not going
over there to read dad babes for those
people back then to stoner birder freak
you know what we call him now
people people yeah it's kind of got
watered down though the pot you know
everybody smokes pot everyone doesn't
know it's it's not as edgy as it used to
be not as dangerous you know more people
smoke pop and eat Brad bell
you want to be a bad boy make some toast
but I have a hoagie listen to Dark Side
of the Moon so head I can't a soup the
other night that's the right response
[Music]
even the directions on a can of soup are
pathetic
heat in stir do you think you could do
that loser you screwed up the rest of
your life you think you could heat and
stir the soup you know what just stir it
we're gonna send somebody over to heat
it for you you know why soup says heated
stir on it because it can't say open the
window and jump
I guess what I'm saying is I need buddy
I'm not super poor but I know exactly
how much money I have in the bank at all
times that's a bad place to be when you
know exactly how much what do you have
it's like I'm eight I have 44 dollars
now my buddy said at least you got your
health like ooh I get to be poor for a
long time
he proposed the buddy he's always like
buddy changes you I sure hope so
I just had a kid a soup a lot of bad
news out there though a lot of bad news
like the sexual misconduct that's better
did the news all the time dough it's a
big bummer
a huge bummer so do pervert everyday
everyday there's a new program I used to
think I knew what a pervert was with all
this news and information I finally
looked the word up
you know the pervert is appropriate is a
guy
you